here we have a hemoglobin structure with
the pdb id
2 hbs
this structure is a mutant which is
known to cause sickle cell disease
upon examining the interface between the
two globular regions it appears that
certain residues have their side chains
shown to select one of the atoms in
these side chains use
plus left click
to broaden the scope of the selection
use the up arrow and to narrow the scope
use the down arrow
you can use the right arrow to invert
the selection
and the left arrow to undo the last
selection action
to select multiple atoms at once
use ctrl shift and left click
to select a broader region of the
protein keep the control button pressed
down and use a left mouse drag to reveal
a rectangle
upon releasing the mouse everything
within the rectangle becomes selected
pressing the control button and clicking
outside of the structure deselects the
selected region
chimera's command line is readily
accessible under the favorites menu
now we can use the command line to
perform selections within the structure
unsurprisingly the key word for these
commands is select
let's say you wanted to select a
particular range of residue positions
within the structure
to do this you would type into the
command line select
colon
and the desired residue position range
upon hitting enter these positions are
highlighted in green
if you wanted to limit the selection to
a particular chain you would type a
period followed by the desired chain
code
now the selection only applies to chain
a
to select a specific residue within a
chain the format is the same as before
except the residue range is replaced
with a single position
to select the same residue position
across a number of chains
simply add a chain range as shown
research has shown that the most common
type of sickle cell disease causing
mutation is a mutation from glutamic
acid to valine at position 6 of the
hemoglobin beta chain chain h
to locate this position we can select by
sequence
upon selecting chain h we are greeted
with the entire amino acid sequence of
that chain
hovering over each of these letters
reveals the position id label at the
bottom of the window
in this way we eventually come to valine
6.
to select this residue click and drag
over its letter
notice the residue highlighted in the
graphics window
now under actions atoms and bonds we can
show the side chain
and then
we can focus in on the residue
once you have obtained a clear view of
the residue you may want to label it to
do this go to actions label
residue and choose name plus specifier
this label provides the three letter
code of the amino acid its number and
its chain
you can adjust label parameters such as
font size by again going to actions
label and options
the label comes in small so it's a good
idea to set the font size to something
larger
if you would like the label to contrast
with the surrounding protein you can go
to actions
color
and under all options selectively apply
the coloring to residue labels
then you can choose a color that
provides better contrast